madrid reste à droite
selon des résultats quasi définitifs le
parti populaire a remporté 44 % des voix
lors des élections régionales de la
capitale espagnole ce mardi une victoire
pour la présidente sortante de la région
isabelle dias ayuso aujourd'hui un
nouveau chapitre de l'histoire de
l'espagne commence parce qu'aujourd'hui
depuis madrid depuis le kilomètre zéro
nous allons récupérer la fierté le
sentiment d'appartenance la culture de
l'effort et surtout le vivre ensemble
l'unité et la liberté dont l'espagne a
besoin aujourd'hui c'est un nouveau
départ aujourd'hui commence à nouveau
départ un nouveau départ célébré dans
les rues madrilènes ce mardi soir ce
scrutin particulièrement suivis à
mobiliser la région malgré la pandémie
avec plus de 5 millions d'électeurs aux
urnes forte de sa stratégie en faveur
des entreprises et contre les
restrictions strictes
isabelle dias ayuso a su convaincre les
gens voulaient vraiment de la stabilité
et c'est une réponse à ce que nous avons
vécu pendant la pandémie avec la
situation de co vide
donc je pense que ce résultat est tout à
fait normal honnêtement je suis assez
heureuse cela va être très bon pour
madrid parce que tous les endroits vont
être ouverts les entrepreneurs vont
pouvoir gagner de l'argent et continuer
à travailler et cela va être tellement
bénéfique pour nous tous
surtout pour l'économie
honnêtement isabelle diaz ayuso a fait
une grande campagne
je pense que cela va être la meilleure
chose pour madrid nous allons enfin
avoir ce que nous avons toujours voulu
un magret de libre pour tout le monde
ceux qui pensent différemment pour tout
le monde finalement nous sommes super
heureux nous avons fait la fête tout en
gardant à l'esprit les mesures du coc
vide et nous sommes tellement heureux
une véritable douche froide pour la
gauche du chef du gouvernement pedro
sanchez particulièrement investi dans
cette campagne le parti socialiste perd
ainsi 12 députés régionaux
nous allons analyser ce qui s'est passé
évidemment nous ne pensons pas que les
résultats soient bons c'est évident et
nous ne nous attendions pas à cela
c'est aussi vrai nous avions espéré que
ce que nous proposions aurait pu marcher
et se donne un manifestement pas été le
cas et c'est dans deux ans nous nous
reverrons lors des élections je suis sûr
qu'au cours de ces deux années nous nous
trouverons notre vitalité
nous montrerons nos capacités et nous
analyserons ce que nous devons
réorienter dans ce scrutin le président
du gouvernement espagnol perd un allié
de taille à l' annonce des résultats
pablos iglesias chef du parti gauche
radicale podemos annoncé son retrait de
la politique un scrutin local qui a
pourtant des airs de test national en
espagne
à deux ans des prochaines élections
législatives espagnoles cette victoire
de la droite pourrait être décisive pour
l'avenir politique du pays